So, we have the number 35. The 3 is in the tens place
so it represents 30 or 3 tens—
one 10, two groups of 10, three groups of 10
and then the 5 is in the ones place
so it represents five ones. We see them right over here
—one, two, three, four, five.
Now, we want to take that 35 or those 3 tens
and 5 ones and add 6. 6 ones.
The 6 is in the ones place—
one, two three, four, five, six ones.
And I encourage you to pause the video
and try to do that. Add 35 to 6.
So let's think about it now.
So I'm gonna start with the ones.
So I have 5 ones and I want to add 6 ones.
So what's that going to be altogether?
Well, 5 ones plus 6 ones, that's going to be 11 ones
and I still have 3 tens so we could say it's going to be
3 tens, 3 tens and 11 ones.
3 tens, I could write, plus 11 ones here.
Now this is a little bit of a problem because
we can't write a two-digit number
in the ones place or in any one of the places.
I can't, this number isn't going to be 311.
It's going to be 3 tens and 11 ones
but how can I rewrite this or how can I regroup things
so that I only have a single-digit number here?
I have zero, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
or nine here instead of a two-digit number— the 1 one.
Well, I can regroup. I can say,
"Look, I have enough ones here to create a group of ten."
I could take 10 of them, so let's take these 10,
right over here, and put them together
and make a new group of ten.
So, a new group of ten right over there.
So if I take, so just to be clear, what I just did
I just took these 10, these 10 ones
and I stuck them together and I turned it
into this new group of, this new group of ten.
So now what do we have?
So when you regroup like this you see that you have
one, two, three, four tens. 4 tens.
And how many ones do you have now?
4 tens plus? Well, I've regrouped all of these 10 ones
and all I have left is this 1 one right over there.
So I could write this as 4 tens plus 1 one.
Once again, 3 tens and 11 ones,
that's the same thing as 4 tens and 1 one.
And so we can write that over here,
we can write this as, 1 one and 4 tens.
Now how could you get this if you weren't,
if you didn't do it like this and drawing everything out
and regrouping like this and this is actually
what you should be doing in your head
but another way of thinking about it, you could say,
"Alright 5 plus 6," that's going to be 11 ones
but I can't write an 11 here in the ones place
so I could say, "That's going to be the same thing
as 1 ten plus 1 one." 1 ten plus 1 one.
Sometimes it's taught that 5 plus 6 is 11,
carry the 1 but really what you're doing is you're saying,
"5 plus 6 is 1 ten plus 1 one."
And, in fact, an 11, the number 11 right over here.
So if I were to write the number 11, the number 11
has a 1 in the tens place and a 1
in the ones place so it's 1 ten plus 1 one.
So you're just saying that 5 plus 6 is 11
which is the same thing as 1 ten and 1 one
and then you add your tens together—
1 ten plus another 3 tens is going to be 4 tens.
But I really want you to appreciate what's going on.
You're not just blindly saying, "Oh, 5 plus 6 is 11
so I'm going to write 1 of the ones here
and write the 1 in the tens place here."
You're doing it because you're regrouping.
You're regrouping that group of ten.
You're saying, "Hey I could take 10 of these ones
and I can turn them into a new group of ten
and that would just leave me 1 in the ones place.
1 in the ones place and I've just turned
all the other ones into a new group of ten.